the Republican Civil War is not letting
up anytime soon in fact it's growing
Republican you know I don't I don't want
to say Insider but establishment
Republican Paul Ryan a major figure in
the last you know 10 15 years of
Republican politics is now openly saying
we will lose if Trump is the nominee
I am anti-trump and I will not go to the
Republican National Convention in 2024
if Donald Trump is indeed the nominee
let's take a look at a couple of very
interesting Clips here is Paul Ryan
speaking at the Tommy Thompson Center on
public leadership and he says I'm not
for Trump because I want to win I'm a
never again Trumper because I want to
win
he we're going to lose with him look the
evidence is pretty clear we lost the
house in 18 because of trump we lost the
presidency obviously in 20 because of
trump we lost the senate in 20 because
of trump then there are I by my account
five Senate seats this cycle in 22 we
lost because of trump and by most sort
of smart people in our party by most of
their measurements we lost about 12 to
15 seats in the house because of trump
so Kevin McCarthy would have had a nice
20 some vote cushion I had an upper for
Trump so the point I'm making is we know
we lose with him and so we know we will
lose with him again if we nominate this
guy especially and January 6 happened
after the 20 election
so you think he became more popular with
swing voters in the wild counties you
know since January 6th so it is my point
is we're going to lose with the guy so
let's now
is Paul Ryan correct about this I
actually don't know I mean listen if you
look at the latest polling
it doesn't look terrible for Trump
assuming he can win the Republican
nomination you look at a recent Emerson
College poll released
um released I think today uh taken
February 24th and 25th there's an A
minus rated pollster on Biden versus
Trump they have Trump uh plus three
um in the popular vote
it's February almost March of 2023 so we
you could say this isn't really worth
much but it is not obvious that Trump
can't win if he does become the nominee
in 2024 a morning consult which is a
b-rated pollster has Biden plus two
against Trump
um in an Echelon insights poll has Biden
plus three over Trump the point is it's
not a foregone conclusion that Donald
Trump can't defeat Joe Biden if that's
the rematch uh of 2020 in 2024 but Paul
Ryan's opinion is that Trump can't win
and he wants to win now we have a couple
of other Clips here is Paul Ryan being
interviewed by Fox 6 uh and he is
continuing to pile on I'm backing the
person not named Donald Trump so I I
don't really have a dog in the fight
other than that if we nominate Trump
again we're going to lose again it's
just that clear we lost with him in 18
20 and 22 we know this he will cost us
another election so I'm just excited
about somebody not named yeah and then
just one more clip here of Paul Ryan
saying he will not attend the Republican
National Convention if Trump is the
nominee for the Republican National
Convention in Milwaukee where will you
be it uh it depends on who the nominee
is
I'll be here if it's somebody not named
Trump
you won't show up if it's not yeah I'm
not interested in participating in that
no even Wisconsin
even Wisconsin so listen there's a
really let's there's two parts to this
there's the Republican Civil War aspect
to it and there's the Ken Trump win
aspect which we don't have a definitive
answer to right now the Civil War part
continues to be uh very interesting
where you see people in the vein of Paul
Ryan Mitt Romney Adam kinzinger and
others who have the I hate to call it
audacity they just have the sort of uh
honesty I guess to say what we know more
Republicans than just them are thinking
they don't care if they are on the outs
when it comes to being friendly with
those who are in positions of power if
Trump wins and Trump's in power we all
know Paul Ryan will have no influence
Mitt Romney will have no influence and
they're okay with that for one reason or
another fine okay let that that's no no
problem whatsoever the question of
listen
in 18 Republicans did poorly because of
trump
in 20 they lost the Senate and they lost
the presidency and then in 22 the red
wave that was supposed to be actually
saw them lose a seat in the Senate and
take the slimmest of minorities in the
house Trump's been a disaster completely
true the reason I wouldn't count out
Trump in 24 if he is indeed the nominee
is when you are out of power and you are
making the argument things are terrible
and you've got to put me back in to fix
it as transparent as that is as you and
I of course know just like Trump made
all these promises he didn't keep in
2016 and just like he wouldn't have kept
the promises he made in 2020 he's not
going to do any of the things he's going
to do he's not going to fix any of the
problems that he claims he's going to
fix if he wins in 24 but being on the
outside and being able to say everybody
in power is ruining it bring me in and I
will fix it that can actually motivate
people who otherwise wouldn't vote at
all to vote and that may actually be
what the 24 election hinges on so I
would not assume that Trump can't win
and I think that it would be a very big
mistake to do what many did in 2016
which is to laugh off the idea of trump
at least now we know he did once win and
that should remind us he could win again
but the Civil War aspect of this is
going to become very interesting
particularly as more candidates
announced that they are going to be
running against Trump in that Republican
primary race so we're going to continue
following all of it I do want to invite
you to subscribe to the YouTube channel
at youtube.com the davidpackman show we
do desperately need your help in getting
to that 2 million subscriber number and
I also want to remind you we are now
dubbing uh roughly two-thirds of our
daily content into the Spanish language
elements of Spanish you can find on the
Spanish Channel at davidpackman.com
Spanish Let Your Friends neighbors
parents cousins anybody who is looking
for this type of content but in Spanish
rather than English let them know
davidpackman.com Spanish